so what i would do is i would sit down
and i would map out my day and my day is
very important
an agent of mine said if you're not
doing 10 phone calls for your business
for your career
you're not doing your job and i said oh
thanks for that
that gave me gold ten calls this that
would be ten emails you ten reaching out
ten
connecting with somebody on linkedin or
trying to do something
can i get an appointment to go and meet
a new manager right
i might not be ready but i show them my
video and they'll give me the feedback
and they'll say we're looking looking
for this and then you try to tweak it to
that and now you show them they go yeah
and you they you prove that you do the
work you know they're gonna take it
people are looking for
good talent right they need to know that
you're
out there doing the work don't take no
as a no so i'd map out my day
and this between this hour and this hour
i am doing
um my avails i am sending out emails i'm
making phone calls
and i'm mailing packages i'm doing
that no other comics doing
because what is every comic doing
they're sending out a link
or somewhere even worse hey google me
or look me up on youtube you're going to
have a comic or are you going to have a
booker
uh do the extra work to find your video
it should be right there
and then um so i'll send them something
you know i'll find a way to send them
something
and i'll send them lunch you know send
them lunch and a and a qr code
you know while you're eating your lunch
uh you know take a bit use this qr code
to look at my six minutes
interesting in a neat little card and
i'll call the club call the club
call the club finally say well what is
what does tommy like to eat
for lunch well he likes his chinese
place right down right next door
and it's like what's his favorite and
gives me and then i'll call that place
and
send them the card to send over with
this with the food
buy them lunch and it's from jerry
corley here use this to check out my
video
and they're like oh nobody does
that so that's
a certain portion of the day that's
dedicated just to that then our next
another portion of the day is dedicated
to
my my joke writing uh and then another
part of the day is
dedicated to my social media or whatever
with and it's hard man it's hard to do
all of that
yeah but if you think of yourself like
an enterprise
all of those things are different
departments in your enterprise
and your day job is your revenue part of
your
business you know that's bringing in the
revenue to help you to put food on the
table and survive and
keep your business moving along as it
starts as you're working that startup
you know but if you don't divide that
time and put it in your date book or put
it on your
on your phone as a time reserved for
this
as an appointment for yourself then
you're not going to get to it
yeah and at the end of the day and this
may have been something ted alexandro
said on here
but it's well one thing he said was that
you'll never regret working harder
which i enjoyed but it is also like
you're willing
to structure your day around a boss
you may not like so why wouldn't you
also show the same discipline to
yourself into your comedy career
and structure your day around a career
you actually want to pursue
so at the end of the day a lot of people
want the magic bullet
but it is like hey schedule it
and commit to it and the more you do
that the easier that habit becomes and
the more
just reflexive it becomes that's why the
right ten clubs started in quarantine
we've been doing it over six months
because i was like
oh man i'm about to we're i don't know
when live shows are coming back
i need motivation to write i was like
well let me just start writing online
and see what happens and now it's grown
into
this like international online writing
community
but it all started with me like i need
some sort of accountability so every day
at 10 a.m
i'm just gonna write and now it's grown
into this community
but it all does start i think with
scheduling it
and then like you said having uh having
coaches
or um that's kind of like a built-in
accountability system so it's not all on
you
hold yourself accountable to someone
else and
i like the micro gains as well of a lot
of the times we try to
write that next great hour in one
sitting but sometimes it's like
hey i i wrote a setup punch no it's not
funny
no it really doesn't make sense no i'll
never say it but i sat down
and i exercised the muscle of writing
and that's the victory today
check it off i scheduled it i did it and
the more you do that the easier it'll
become
yep exactly jerry seinfeld used to have
a calendar and it had you know he put a
red x in every day that he wrote and the
idea was don't break the chain don't
break the chain don't break the chain
so if you keep that habit up it's so
much easier to keep it